[Music]
thank you very much everybody uh how
about a round of applause for my
pants
yeah it's worth mentioning these are
these are pants worth mentioning old
pety pumpkin pants this jacket says hey
I'm a cool guy and the pants say just
kidding everybody relax I'm just a
regular dork it's gonna be fine uh so
happy Halloween I'm excited it's
Halloween happy Halloween to all of you
and can I just say one thing right up
top to those families those houses that
are uh giving out the full siiz candy
bars to all the trick-or-treaters uh on
behalf of all of
us go
yourself you're making the rest of us
look like cheap skates you're ruining it
you overachieving sons of why
not just hand out little ice cream
Snickers bars and little freezers they
can actually take home or just hand out
$50 bills if you're so desperate for an
8-year-old's approval you creeps I mean
I get decorating all crazy on Christmas
it's like there's so much joy in my
heart it just spills out into the yard
but on Halloween what's that it's just I
have so much evil in my heart I need to
make children
cry it's not scary it's just weird the
scariest thing about Halloween as an
adult isn't the uh you know the houses
or the
ghouls as an adult the scariest thing is
the uh costume picking out a costume as
a grown person it's terrifying as a kid
it was easy you like Spider-Man it was
simple you go to the store you buy a
8.95 Spider-Man in a bag comes with the
mask comes with the smok you know the
the official Spider-Man smok with
Spider-Man's face on the smok not
exactly what Spider-Man would actually
wear it more looks like what he would
put on if he was cutting your
hair but still you got the idea I'm
Spider-Man deal with it give me candy
it's fun but as an adult picking a
costume is a nightmare because it's got
to be that weird blend of recognizable
but also unique
cuz you can't just be like one of seven
Walter whites at a party just like I
shaved my head for
this like you think you got it bad I
gave myself
cancer what I'm saying is it's
overwhelming it's got to be original
funny comfortable attractive and you can
make a very good argument with all this
pressure for not dressing up at all and
just staying in and every year I'm not
lying every year I Almost Do I almost
just say forget it all but then I
realized I'd be that weird house on the
block with the lights off and no candy
for the children a real
monster an adult who hates fun so at the
very last second I always decide to like
throw together a costume just based on
the stuff I have in my house which is
hard it's like being high at night when
all the restaurants are
closed so you have to like mgy or a meal
out of just whatever you have you got
like a what's this a ketchup packet some
soy sauce single piece of crusty white
bread you're just salty tomato
sandwich this is disgusting and I'm
high in some ways people who don't like
Halloween are right you know what I mean
it's stressful it's silly it's annoying
but we need to remember that fun is
sometimes a choice you know what I'm
saying sometimes you got to take a
chance take a chance you'll be one of
seven Batman at a party take a chance
that you might have to drunkenly piss
inside of your Iron Man's suit cuz you
couldn't figure out the plate thing in
time take a chance of being the guy in
the runny Darth Mall makeup trying to
make out with little B
peep you want to see my double-edged
lightsaber because sometimes it's better
to be wrong and have fun than write and
be alone that's Halloween
[Music]
baby